une municipalité de 15000 habitants
située à une heure de la frontière
canadienne
c'est ici que se trouve l'université
clarkson réputé pour ses programmes en
finance et en ingénierie une université
qui vibre aussi au rythme de ses équipes
de hockey au décor purement amérique
et pourtant chez match grâce à un gène
québec dans cette mare à boucherville
je viens de le buzzer je viens ses
membres québec personne c'est le petit
québec de l'acier cette année huit
joueurs québécois sont répartis dans les
équipes masculine et féminine de hockey
plus que dans tout autre université
américaine
ces décès comme le fait académique et
sportif parfait vue clarkson qui était 5
heures de route de chez moi puis quand
je suis venu visiter j'ai juste germain
mlq en perspective il faut remonter aux
années 80 pour trouver la dernière
équipe de hockey qui ne comptait aucun
québécois rrq roczen
le hockey universitaire à potsdam c'est
une véritable religion look est vraiment
populaire ce qui comparé après des
places nous unit et comme on dirait que
c'est quand même la partie la plus
canadienne des deux suivent ce peace
alpes et keith hampton hôpitaux demande
qu'à maquiller comme axa beau stylo qui
pour eux aussi c'est ce qui se passe
vraiment dans les équipes comptent aussi
beaucoup de succès sur la glace
[Musique]
elisabeth giguère est la meilleure
buteuse aux états unis l'équipe
masculine elle est classé dans les cinq
meilleurs au pays à l'heure actuelle on
gagne ça c'est un portable les gars on
cherche pour les personnes qui ont
motivé son école puis sur la glace us il
[Musique]
ignoré au repêchage de la ligue de
hockey junior majeur du québec ses
joueurs rêvent encore à la ligue
nationale de hockey
beaucoup d'équipés la ligue nationale
qui viennent qui regardent bernier
partie même si c'est un peu dans un
milieu de parole c'est l'occasion de
parler à deux équipes données 3d on a
cinq jours qui a suivi de contrats dans
l'hymne national
tous les joueurs arrivés ici avec
pour les attirer et les aider à
décrocher leur diplôme les universités
américaines n'hésitent pas à verser à
plusieurs joueurs québécois d
importantes bourses d'études pouvant
aller jusqu'à 100 mille dollars
canadiens par année
tous nos joueurs les chiffres jouer
professionnel merci ça marche pas et
donne une bombe ont chacun leurs options
pour les autres dans le bi toutes mes
amies toutes les joueurs que je connais
qui ont joué dans les dix neuf ans jose
québec puisque si je peux le dire à 100%
tout les joueurs que je connais s'y
avère frères qui avaient regardé en
attendant les québécois et québécoises
de klaxons compte accrocher une autre
bannière de champions nationaux dans les
hauteurs du cheo rina ici michael roy a
pas dix dames dans l'état de new york
m